spend more on marketing period this
might be crazy for you so i looked at
our total lifetime spent on marketing
and our total uh dollars made and we
have a 35 to 1 return on our ad spend
lifetime i should just spend more money
but when i talk to people who are
smaller in their businesses
they're afraid to spend money getting
people to make that first step is one of
them the second one is increasing their
price the third one is paying for talent
the best people need to get paid like
the best people and so thinkers need to
pay to be paid much more than you expect
and doers need to get paid less because
a thinker should be able to make the
decision for you and make the right call
in theory you should be able to make a
better call than you and so i don't know
if you've ever like gone to a company
and met an employee and been like man
this employee's freaking awesome like
man if i hit this person on my team i
think the mistake that i've made i try
to
turn a camry into a cadillac trying to
push someone and empower someone who
does not have the skills or does not
have the bandwidth or doesn't have the
attention to actually make good
decisions